I can't believe it I just can't believe
it that was so insane whoa Ram what
happened don't talk to me sweater towns
not accepting calls I just if feel the
moon to the moon you go first I can't
talk I'm just to try the tie you're a
dick
that's what happened I have a dick a
this episode was so intense they scared
my beard off ah actually when you scream
you look like Ernest P war oh yeah so
for those who don't know I had to shave
this for review um and not gonna keep it
this way I really miss my beard you look
like a shaved woodchuck yeah I am I
swear my face has gotten like sadder
like when I'm smiling is fine but watch
why I'm not look at that it's just like
it's like so weird like I haven't shaved
the beard in years and it just it feels
and looks very odd so um so don't worry
I'm not keeping this look I'm gonna keep
it for one more review though because
the next one I can't have a beard in
either but yeah we are doing a dipper
and Mabel versus the future you dick
what you ruined everything for Mabel
well we may have ruined everything for
Mabel what me as dipper or yes you're
wearing the Hat okay looking like
different now hoot oh that's all thank
you remember that's all like thanking
about a ones finger this whole episode
Oh Mabel has chin here hey
now always wearing the sweaters and shit
um but yeah no this was definitely a I
can't I can't wear a sweater today I
have to wear black in mourning this is
it for what if you did
I really feel you're like um you know
just just sort of shifting this anger of
a fictional show on to me how dare you
all I wanted was a good thirteenth
birthday party I didn't get it back then
and I certainly didn't get it today I
guess I I think you're reliving some
Tarin Kowt I was fucking reliving Terra
when Wendy's just like ended Mabel's
like don't do high school go run away oh
you know escape though with me yeah but
it has a sign that's a no escape I'm
like ain't that fucking I love and I
love the reference to a high school
musical like why aren't you singing
about your dreams like in that musical
like making fun of Disney with that they
make some good shots of themselves
really um cuz I mean that is that it's
like okay most people know going in it's
like okay this is like happy Pappy fix
your lies it's a musical and like a
safety was Saved by the Bell we have bad
stuff too uh and honestly I'm kind of
glad cause if I was told the truth high
five yeah well show that I would they
really are right I mean it's just it's
all these hormones all these kids if I
if I were if I were told the truth I
would have stuck my head in the oven at
the end of junior I said you know lit a
match but at least you're learning an
awful lot yeah I remember piss me off
the most I'm in this place I don't want
to be in I remember he's pissed off
we're all pissed off and it's like we're
not learning anything important stay in
school
ah don't do drugs remember drink your
drugs stay in milk and doctor school
yeah um but yeah so uh no that was okay
say Kiki no way you know I knew that you
need was to get by it was the way they
were all standing in the gym like
zombies yeah did I bring everything I'm
like I'm like wow that was literally
like the first day of like every year of
high school for me honestly that was
about the first day of school for every
day for me but
no honestly whatever in the morning or
whatever I'm driving by and I see skids
waiting at the school bus don't you just
go oh thank fucking god ha ha ha well I
was gonna say no I go oh yeah no that's
just like it and it's terrible but it's
like you know it's like we do our time
you know we just do our time we get
through it a man wish I sure I served my
time yeah now I get to make fun of the
other dumb criminals yeah um we're get
really as I attacked her though uh I
mean I don't know in a sense what
episode was so morose it was it really
captured that feeling of the
end-of-summer like wow this is it
you are gonna wondering what it was
gonna come I was almost thing like so is
it gonna be the end of the show is when
and the summer comes or what um uh
depressing and I was getting one thanks
to you you know what shut the fuck up
Mabel shut the fuck up I'm gonna say
you're the reason that the whole world
is gone now you all know world
y'all know words that will we have well
maybe if you didn't betray me I'm sorry
I was guy sounds gonna think it over you
were supposed to hear about the bomb
walkie talkie I was just saying that to
make him happy
there is no sweater that can cover up
the hole in my soul for that oh my god I
should have been a while yeah that's a
great life
sweater watch by the way cuz I keep
forgetting uh dick did ya birthday cake
at propose sand uh that's French see I
studied ins yeah nice and uh you learned
in high school I did no I actually I
took Spanish in high school yeah um I
don't know which is probably the most
useful thing you could take and they
don't write out why don't anything is
why don't like anything is I don't
remember any of it um and now I wish I
did um oh and uh like a nightshirt or
something like a disk drive oh yeah yeah
that's or not a district obvious yeah
joe says that old song lucky disc I
don't see those anymore uh you know what
uh and actually the code at the end I've
been doing the codes for the last ones
files like hello let me see what this
says the low code in the end credits was
did you miss me obviously referring to
bill cipher and then uh the actual the
error codes and the wheel and stuff like
that spelled out like just this I can't
say wear Footwear bills like just this
really haunting poem about like you know
it the prophecy has been so long but now
it's here to stay you know embrace the
embrace the strange now everything will
change and stuff it's just like oh
that's creepy
oh and swatch alert for last time since
I missed it it was to pine trees not
really not that interesting there we go
probably I didn't bring it up oh you
know what the sweaters are important
ruin everything else they had her in the
sweat the sweater watch to the situation
is speaking of which I thought that was
no I thought that was very little
kiddush of her you know
don't pick your head in the sand just
covering yourself up yeah I thought that
was very limited town accepted calls at
the moment um and yeah you don't play
okay I felt I feel bad for her yeah well
is heck no we finally come to something
they were building up and I thought they
almost forgot about which was sort of
that the separation between the two in
that distance that was gonna grow at all
I didn't think they forgot because they
made such a big deal out of it was only
at the end of one episode and then it's
like I was weighted away you know I was
- I was kind of like I both did and
didn't want to see it happen um but he
was doing it in a way that was like it's
understandable summers do and and you
know he's offered something that really
is amazing and he would obviously love
um but it was kind of like just like I
couldn't let her stay - I don't know if
I gotta let them stay the whole summer I
me as that you would think the parents
don't care that much or whatever I mean
beylin does seem to be some absentee
parent um anybody who would leave their
kids with grunkle Stan that is the very
definition of absentee beer um so I
don't know that's the one thing it's not
going I don't want to leave them I don't
I don't want a parent and I don't want
to leave them with a parent mmm it is
absentee parenting them every single
level you're gonna mess um but uh yeah I
mean it's like you said it is very
morose that not that many laughs really
um ya know it was most of the laughs
were just kind of especially the high
school stuff I was like oh so true well
and we we moved around a lot uh and
the time we've had a chance to say
goodbye to all our friends and stuff
like that everyone's why you kind of
like or even if not you're just leaving
a place and you know may not seem again
you don't know like you always kind of
miss that one or two people and it's
kinda like oh shit I may never see that
person again
oh well yeah so I say yeah you know I
just want those things where it's like
it doesn't ruin your aenthul your
cowlick yeah Cass sucks you know so I
was came from I know that when she was
going to her friends like and they were
saying they weren't gonna be around for
you know the end of summer oh you were
completely in the dark
yes I am you know I am gonna bring that
up because that actually is driving me
crazy
um hey kinda sorta maybe closer sister I
mean uh now we're gonna be like you know
nuclear but anyway uh shit but um I mean
aside from that it was mostly kind of
just building the cliffhanger uh 20
points for the flight of the navigator
ship being yeah the walnut the flying
yeah that was really how my dad has to
be a fly - yeah I mean it's like I guess
we could be kind of stretching because
they have a few things in there but if
it fucking won't like it it'd look a lot
like it close enough for me yeah I'll
take it
um but uh yeah I mean now we have the
end of the world
I'm sure um but it's I I don't know if
this is the end of season two or if it's
I know that end was coming up so I don't
know if this was the actual and but yeah
I was curious like how they were gonna
run this out with summer because I'm
like how long is this summer I'm not
gonna lie but did I not turn to you when
they'd start running the end credits
with just the the 13th birthday party
poster there and everybody's screaming
in the laser sounds and just said I
would pay a thousand dollars if it just
ended here ha ha ha like so excited just
as the engine like holy fuck do a duck
man do a if you haven't seen the body of
so Johnny and is not even a clue Fagor
just well guess it was the end of the
world Oh
this is it the end of the world
whoa yeah doctor that the Peppa that the
lights unfair oh shoot um but yeah bye
if you haven't seen the last episode
duck man it is the biggest fuck you it
ends on a cliffhanger that they
purposefully never answer um and the
sort of this sort of cliffhanger that
you're like holy shit - yeah it's like
it's treated really seriously it's like
to be continued question mark and it's
like what the fuck cuz I'm pretty sure
they knew they weren't gonna get another
season uh or maybe they did I don't know
but anyway again getting off topic I
mean good episode for something that's
basically just building up a big
cliffhanger um and but it still felt the
drama was very genuine and like like
that I felt like the UFO was a nod to
lost as well yeah going to the wall yeah
yeah that long climb down the ladder and
I liked the idea of the UFO being there
- yeah no I thought that's really cool
sort of the shape there and everything
you got wonder if that's a UH Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull reference must we
Sully this head show by bringing up
Kingdom if it still snow I did in mind
that see with the the taking idea was
silly but I'm just like you know Kennedy
was really fake those need the aliens
were no more silly than Cate Blanchett
in the mo Howard haircut it isn't really
they couldn't even give us a cool death
with her it's like all the other bills
get these cool bloody Dez and she's like
oh no light I'm light oh so yeah I had
no problem with aliens because he was
running out of religion nothing like a
fucking alien they've ever done I just
thought the execution in that film was
sloppy but the very idea that actually
her execution you know what we can't
have
aliens sewing up our Holy Grail Hindu
demon Ark of the Covenant God Ratignolle
so long but this is going over line yeah
um but I mean it's it's a good episode I
mean I can't say it's like wow one of my
favorites or anything I actually think
the clip I will say it was emotionally
affecting for this show
I was no there was really this sense of
kind of sadness dread I was we didn't
see where was going first cuz I didn't
want to feel like it was too
manipulative um and when it actually got
to him and her talking I was like okay
no this feels right it wasn't like a
liar revealed it wasn't it you weren't
supposed to hear that thing I mean it's
like he comes clean says no look this is
something that's you know this does
happen you know and it does it's just
like it's just fucking light these
things do happen uh you know it's not
while that's really force contrived
plots so I was happy to see it went that
direction um yeah yeah dick dick dude if
I was there I won't call bells bill
cipher because I think we both did were
just like that's so fucking decipher her
and now we know who he was she was
anyway she was emotionally distraught
well keep in mind I don't has dipper
been keeping her informed because I know
what's his face at oh he can possess
people he'll do anything to get this
thing
I don't know Mabel was ever in for no no
no remember dipper the puppet one I mean
he flat-out said you know I it's me
they'll cipher Big Dipper yeah when they
hit but has dipper been keeping Mabel
informed about what's going on I don't
think so
Oh probably she didn't know what the
fuck that thing was she had no idea my
guess is if she did she may have thought
twice about one again I think you nailed
it where it's like she wasn't she was
vulnerable
if you had actually fucking talked to
her she ran off
well yeah cuz you were being such a boy
this is it we've made such a girl you
and you're giving away the universe just
like Adam and Eve now the world's
destroyed because I'm more interested in
the sweaters in this goddamn show
doesn't make me oh my god it makes me um
but no I think you know Denali was she
in a vulnerable spot but it was their
kids you know and that's something where
it's like and I think you don't actually
do this does bring up a point because
the UM the character design on those two
like what they're just like we're gonna
be turning 13 that was like bullshit ha
ha ha this is like you love your dammit
your
no I'm like you're gonna be turning ten
I'll believe eleven but I was like 13
yeah I was heaven I was having trouble
with that well that's one you just have
to have the same you know character
design whatever um so it's okay I just
was like they're 12 really like I always
forget that they're 12 I'm like I just
and some people came through they learnt
when some people go through growth
spurts late you know do I know 10 it was
where it seemed like Mabel talked to
Wendy say yeah I'm gonna be here in like
another year or two and I'm like really
oh yeah but no I agree
um but yeah still good episode like I
said not sure if it's gonna be the last
one for the season or not I mean if so
it's a good cliffhanger and if not it's
gonna cliffhanger I won't know what's
gonna happen oh yeah um that's about it
and we may or may not see you uh very
soon with the next episode helene if it
isn't the last of season 2 they usually
take al I'm sure I'm sure we'll be told
ya know I'm sure people tell us in the
comments so uh yeah that's about it and
we will see you late on I'll play the
beer we'll come back on my birthday
shut up you obvious ten-year-old